Welcome, everybody, to what has been mostly
mostly sunny but rainy today, Martha's Vineyard.
I have so much to talk about.
We'll talk a little bit about the show break
on the bonus show when Pat joins me.
We're going to talk about council culture
later on today.
I do have some segments planned about what's
going on with Corona virus cases versus deaths,
which I got a bunch of e-mails about over
the weekend.
But to start with, we have to talk about this
complete softball propaganda interview that
Donald Trump was given on Fox News, which
still managed to go completely and horribly
wrong.
And as you know, one of the themes of the
presidency of Donald Trump has been self-inflicted
damage because a ton of the stuff that has
gone wrong for Donald Trump has been self-inflicted.
It's been because of his own doing.
Had he not been spouting off on Twitter, for
example, for months and months and months,
the entire Russia probe would likely have
come and gone with a lot less grief for Donald
Trump than than what ended up being an ex
of very, very much extended fiasco.
Had Donald Trump simply avoided extraneous,
belligerent statements about Corona virus,
it's going to go away.
Fifteen cases will go to zero.
And if instead he focused on building a testing
program quickly that worked, we wouldn't be
in the shape that we're in right now.
I can give you more examples, but I think
you get this idea of self-inflicted damage
from Donald Trump.
Donald Trump went on Sean Hannity's Fox News
program and he was given a complete softball
propaganda interview.
The crowd was filled with sycophants who felt
bad for how tough things had been for him.
Hannity at this point, you know, is a friend
of Donald Trump's.
He was seen recently getting on to Donald
Trump's Marine One helicopter in advance of
Trump getting on.
They went somewhere together.
They regularly speak.
So so.
So Hannity interviewing Trump at this point
is very similar to like when Don Junior interviewed
Donald Trump recently.
It's the type of stuff you expect in North
Korea.
But the difference is Trump is so incompetent
that even his son or his friend, Sean Hannity,
giving him the most softball of softball interviews,
still can't make him look good.
So let's get into it.
Donald Trump is, of course, running for reelection.
I've been saying for a while now there's been
no coherent case made for why people should
vote for Donald Trump other than Trump attacking
Joe Biden, which he's been doing for a while.
So Trump was teed up this easy question, hey,
what would your second term priorities be?
What would you focus on in a second term?
Easy opportunity.
And Trump couldn't name anything.
Take a look at this.
If you hear one hundred and thirty one days
from now, at some point in the night or early
morning, we can now project Donald J.
Trump has been reelected.
The 40 foot president of the United States.
Let's talk about it.
What's at stake in this election as you compare
and contrast?
And what is what are your top priority items
for a second term?
Well, one of the things that will be really
great.
You know, the word experience is still good.
I always say talent is more important than
experience.
I've always said that.
But the word experience is a very important
word.
It's in a very important meeting.
I never did this before.
I never slept over in Washington.
I was in Washington, I think 17 times.
All of a sudden I'm president of the United
States.
You know, the story of riding down Pennsylvania
Avenue with our first lady.
And I say, this is great, but I didn't know
very many people in Washington wasn't my thing.
I was from Manhattan, from New York.
Now I know everybody and I have great people
in the administration.
You make some mistakes like, you know, an
idiot like Bolton who want to do is drop bombs
on everybody.
You don't have to drop bombs on everybody.
You have to kill people.
Sometimes you have John Bolton, in fact, released
classified material.
Should he be prosecuted?
Oh, absolutely.
Well, he did release classified, actually.
This is a so this is the softball of softballs
from Sean Hannity and Donald Trump just can't
answer it.
Experience is important.
I never slept over in D.C.
I made a mistake to hire John Bolton.
Let's put this on the screen, and I won't
do this with all of the clips.
But to really understand how ridiculous of
a nonanswer this is to the question, what
are your priorities?
Let's actually look at what Donald Trump said,
quote.
Well, one of the things that will be really
great.
You know, the word experience is still good.
I always say that talent is more important
than experience.
I've always said that.
But the word experience is a very important
word.
It's a very important meaning.
I never did this before.
I never slept over in Washington.
So you get the idea.
So what would your priorities be?
Trump can't name anything.
Here is Donald Trump.
Asked What does he think are the greatest
accomplishments of his first term?
Again, very easy question.
Important.
If you're arguing for people to vote for you
to have a second term, you have to demonstrate
or at least argue that you did something good.
Trump is unable to list anything other than
an Obama policy from 2014 called Veterans
Choice, which we'll talk about.
And the fact that Mitch McConnell forced in
some judges.
So here's the person asking the question.
You'll see just the complete gushing supporter
of Trump.
The question is something I'm calling ultra
cringe.
Let's start there.
The audience has some questions for the president.
We're going to start from Linda.
Hi, Linda from Wausau, Wisconsin.
Thank you for being here with us today.
Say a lot of presidents, all windows, right?
Windows.
You know, I bought a lot of Warsaw windows
over the years.
And, you know, it's I shouldn't give him a
free commercial, but they did a good job.
It's a great window.
They are Wisconsin.
Love it up here.
Thank you.
It's not send your anything my Cuban background.
I have a question for you.
I appreciate so much what you have done for
this country.
And I know it's been tough.
What do you think is your greatest accomplishment
in your eyes?
So a lot of people think it's the fact that
we will have I think, before I finish this
term.
We'll have close to 300 judges, federal judges,
a lot of people think because that's a record,
that's a number that nobody can even believe.
And part of it was that President Obama was
unable to get judges approved in a large number,
about one hundred and forty two judges.
So I took it off, got them approved, and then
got a lot of proof beyond.
So we'll be close to three hundred and two
Supreme Court judges, great ones.
And so I think a lot of people would say that.
So the judge stuff understand it's not really
Trump's doing.
It's really Mitch McConnell's.
I've said before, Mitch McConnell has been
one of the most successful Republican operators
of the last many, many years.
McConnell blocked Barack Obama, getting a
Supreme Court nominee, held the seat open
long enough that Donald Trump was able to
put in Neil Gorsuch, who, of course, was recommended
by somebody else to Donald Trump.
So Trump says judges have been my biggest
accomplishment.
Now, it's true that the people Trump picks
are a disaster, but the reason they're getting
in is because of Mitch McConnell.
The reason they're getting selected is because
conservative groups are telling Trump pick
from this list.
It's not even really a Trump accomplishment,
but it is a very good reason to vote for Joe
Biden.
First of all, then, here's the second part
of Trump's answer where he says, Might one
of my biggest accomplishments is Veterans
Choice, which was an Obama policy from 2014.
And we got Veterans Choice approved and veterans
accountability.
That's where you can fire people that do a
bad job.
You couldn't do it before.
Very hard to get.
They tried to get it for 50 years.
Because the civil service unions essentially
couldn't, you know, get it.
I got it.
And the other thing is veterans should where
if they can't see a doctor, we have great
doctors in the V.A..
But if you can't see a doctor, you go out
and you get a private doctor.
We pay the bill and it's you have no idea
how great it's been.
So Veterans Accountability is B.S.
That's a Marco Rubio bill from 2017.
It's trash.
It's a trash bill.
At least it did happen during Trump's presidency.
The other policy Trump mentions here, Veterans
Choice.
That's a 2014 Obama policy.
Trump made some changes to it.
But understand that what Trump is claiming
to be his biggest accomplishments are Mitch
McConnell getting judges confirmed.
And a 2014 Obama policy.
It's a comedy of embarrassment.
Also funny, by the way, that his one accomplishment,
which is really Obama's, is one where the
government gives people health care.
Trump is right now trying to further damage
Obamacare to take away health care from 20
million people.
And yet he cites as one of his greatest accomplishments,
Trump says, vote for me again because of Obama's
2014 policy, which I tweaked, which gives
free health care through the government, which
most of his supporters are actually against.
Inconceivable.
I mean, just just a laughable joke of an interview.
Then Donald Trump goes into what I call the
sir routine.
The search routine is when Trump retells a
story of someone coming to him and saying
something.
And he always he often says, they came to
me and they said, Sir, X, Y, Z.
Right.
Fill in the blanks.
In this case, it's they came to me and black
people said, Sir, thank you for calling out
something, I guess.
Take a look at this one.
It's a doozy.
We have cities that are worse, in some cases
far worse.
Take a look at Detroit.
Take a look at what's happening in Oakland.
Take a look at what's happening in Baltimore.
And everyone gets upset when I say it.
They say, oh, is that a racist statement?
Just not a racist, frankly.
Black people come up to me, say thank you.
Thank you, sir, for saying it.
They want help cities.
It's like living in hell.
Right.
So black people are coming to Trump asking
him, please, sir, get us out of our hell like
cities.
Does anybody believe that black people who
support Trump at eight percent are coming
to him and thanking him for anything?
And now this gets us to the climax of this
softball interview.
Trump, again, is insisting if we didn't test
for Corona virus, we wouldn't have any cases.
And he goes into this thing of how there are
19 different names for Corona virus.
Take a look.
If we didn't do testing, we'd have no cases.
Other countries that don't test millions.
So I'm almost 30 million tests.
So when you do 30, when you have a kid with
the sniffles and they'll say it's a rotavirus,
whatever you want to call it.
I said the other night, there are so many
names to this.
I could name 19 names like Corona or 19, but
I could name 19 names.
Right.
I mean, listen, if we didn't have Border Patrol,
we would not find anybody crossing the border
illegally.
Problem solved.
Right.
If we didn't ever test for Estes, you'd be
totally clean, right?
No.
Corona virus testing means no cases.
Got it.
It makes perfect sense.
Repeating this again, and as I've said before,
he's had an opportunity to get away from that
horrible answer.
He could frame this in some other way, but
continuing to repeat that bogus framing.
And then here is the day Neumont.
So this is not the climax of the interview.
This is the Danu man, because it's almost
like a sad finale.
Here is Trump almost sounding resigned to
the idea that he's going to lose in November
to Joe Biden.
He's talking like he's already lost.
Listen to this.
Here's a guy doesn't talk.
Nobody hears him, whatever he does.
So he can put two sentences together.
I don't want to be nice or a nice OK, but
I mean, the man can't speak and he's gonna
be a president because some people don't love
me.
Maybe.
And, you know, all I'm doing is doing my job.
Don't forget, before the China play came in
and said China Plague, before they came in,
we had the best job numbers we've ever had.
We had the best economy we've ever had.
Joe Biden is going to be your president because
some people don't love me.
Maybe it's all about Trump.
It's never about you destroyed trade.
It's never about you bungled corona virus.
It's never about you made us the laughingstock
of the world.
Some people don't love me, so they're going
to vote for Joe Biden.
Famous last words, by the way.
We can hope.
But we've got to get out and vote.
So imagine a complete softball propaganda
interview.
Meant to make Trump look good.
That's all.
And Trump couldn't do it in any way, that
made sense.
He misses the gimme, as we say, in golf, which
Donald Trump knows very, very
much about.